like see an urban center vet like many
others around the world is growing and
transforming and there's an invisible
threat here fine dust high
concentrations of airborne particulate
have been measured in latina street it's
narrow and she's heavy traffic all those
cars pose a big problem it's not a good
place to live says physicist and health
research at really Frank he's an expert
on the effects of fine dust during peak
travel times the street gets very
clogged so car emissions intensified
that kicks up a lot of dust then there's
particulates from wear and tear on tires
and brakes and also the exhaust emitted
by the vehicles ironically a major
hazardous posed by emissions that still
aren't limited by Lots incredibly tiny
specks of dust ultrafine particles the
filter on the left is new the other
shows how much fine dust accumulates in
a single day the air is full of it and
that has consequences for a year the
researchers monitored emergency calls
unlikely and they found the correlation
between ultrafine dust levels and people
being rushed to hospitals in many places
worldwide pollution is even higher than
here in countries like India or China or
other developing countries rates of
sickness that are attributable to very
poor air quality are skyrocketing
mortality rates and risks for a variety
of illnesses have risen these can
manifest in the short-term as
respiratory or cardiovascular diseases
or have longer-term consequences like
cancer lung side effect it doesn't so
much because Hong Kong
researchers also measured fine dust
levels in indoor spaces they wanted to
know if it increases a child's risk of
developing bronchitis
they found that risk levels to indeed
rise when smoking occurred in the
child's home or if they lived near
major roads both factors raise
concentrations of ultrafine particles in
the air the scientists also measured
where particulate levels and lapses we
are high and where they were alone look
at these wide green zones in Leipzig for
instance they're not just a source of
fresh oxygen but also serve as long
corridors they allow fresh air to be
brought in and pollutants to be
transported out open urban spaces can
also improve air because they allow for
better ventilation and reduced traffic
an important concept for city planners
even in quickly growing urban centres in
the developing world planners can apply
simple methods that work by choosing to
build one way instead of another you can
significantly reduce the probability of
high pollution levels environmental
zones like this prevent vehicles that
emit large amounts of fine dust from
entering city centers that does help
fight pollution but worldwide there's
still a huge amount of work left to be
done in some cities it had helped to
improve public transportation and others
it's about adapting the cityscape so
it'll be better ventilated and then
there are those we're making industry
cleaner will help industry solve all
tomorrow so reducing fine dust in cities
is possible
and early Frank continues to look for
ways to help urban residents of the
future breathe just a little easier